laut bundesinnenministerium hat die
bundeswehr ja 4500 87 menschen aus kabul
ausgeflogen davon waren knapp 4000
afghane aber nur 138
ortskräfte wie konnte das passieren dass
das nicht kontrollierter ablief einer
der beteiligten jemand der an dieser
evakuierung beteiligt war hat mir das so
beschrieben mit den worten unser
rettungskonzept war clapper auf und wer
reinkommt kommt mit etwas vollkommen
anderes als das was uns die
bundesregierung erzählt hat über wochen
wurde erzählt wir holen jetzt raus
bundeskanzlerin merkel wir wollen vor
allem ortskräfte hätten verteilung des
ministerin annegret kramp karrenbauer
ich möchte jetzt jeder ort kraft
rausholen es gab aber überhaupt kein
konzept dafür wie man weiß wer sind denn
dieser ort kräfte deswegen hat man dann
ein neues konzept eingeführt und das
hieß klappe auf und bei dem cabrio
concept klappe auf kommen natürlich die
menschen mit deswegen sitzen auch vor
allem wenn man sich die fotos anguckt
junge männer in den flugzeugen die
menschen mit die am
robustesten um es mal zurückhaltend
auszudrücken er sich durchgeschlagen
durch geprügelt haben vorbei an den
menschen die wir eigentlich retten
wollten die wahrheit ist wir wissen
nicht wen wir da gerettet haben wir
wissen teilweise nicht mal wer die
menschen sind das eine hoch hohe
relevante zahl von schwerverbrechern
dabei wissen wir inzwischen behörden
gehen davon aus dass man bei einer
niedrig dreistelligen zahl von
schwerverbrechern landen wird die wir
jetzt mit der luftwaffe bequem nach
deutschland gebracht teilweise zurück
gebracht haben die spannende frage der
nächsten tage und wochen wird sein sind
da auch islamisten darunter auch darauf
gibt es schon hinweise und was macht man
dann mit denen dazu würde ich gerne er
steht schon bei uns im studio hinten
rechts am graf lambsdorff von fdp dazu
schön dass sie bei uns wären deshalb
freue mich hier zu sein herzlich
willkommen ja sie haben gerade schon mit
hören können was julian reichelt gesagt
hat die problematik vor der wir jetzt
stehen einerseits wollen wir jetzt
natürlich nicht alle afghanen zu
kriminellen machen andererseits wollen
wir keine straftäter
haben und viele zuschauer viele bürger
in deutschland werden da hin und
hergerissen sein im moment wie gehen wir
damit weiter um also ich glaube
diejenigen die wir kennen und die
straftäter sind und da gibt es übrigens
auch schon 20 leute die müssen sofort in
baut das ist ganz einfach die müssen
ihre rest haftstrafen absitzen wenn es
noch welche gibt und diejenigen bei
denen man es nicht weiß muss man's
recherchieren und die bundespolizei
führt gerade so genannte tiefen
recherchen durch und versucht
herauszufinden wer es wirklich war also
bei den 5000 sind ist diese niedrige
dreistellige zahl vermutlich dabei die
sind problemfeldern aber die rest
haftstrafe ist ja das problem teilweise
sind es nur 87 tage beispielsweise was
passiert dann danach danach wenn wir
dort überwachen müssen zurzeit sind
abschiebungen nicht möglich das muss man
objektiv sehen ist ganz klar und das
wird den steuerzahler geld kosten ist
gar keine frage und das ist das ergebnis
des versagens der bundesregierung ein
ortskräfte konzept rechtzeitig so zu
entwickeln wie die franzosen das gemacht
haben die haben gezielt die leute
rausgeholt dies wirklich verdient hatten
bei uns haben sich die ministerien
untereinander so lange gestritten bis es
dann wirklich knall auf fall klappe auf
losgehen und da gab es kein konzept mehr
aber man kann sich das gar nicht
vorstellen finde ich man kann doch
irgendwie eruieren selektieren vor ort
oder also das kann doch nicht so schwer
sein dass wir vorher sagen der darf
kommen der sollen dh in seinem land
bleiben doch das ist so schwer sie
kennen doch die bilder vom flughafen das
war das nackte chaos das sind da sind ja
unsere länger weil sie es rechtzeitig
gemacht haben unsere bundesregierung hat
es verpennt das ist auch der punkt herr
maas frau kramp karrenbauer und herr
seehofer haben es verpennt auch herr
müller aus dem
entwicklungshilfeministerium weil auch
da gibt es ja viele ortskräfte die
hatten drei verschiedene listen es gab
noch nicht mal eine gemeinsame liste
geschweige denn ein konzept geschweige
denn einen funktionierenden zeitplan das
ergebnis sehen wir jetzt programm
karrenbauer hat ja hier bei bild live
gesagt man muss diese situation jetzt
erstmal hinter sich bringen und dann
will sie für sich persönlich bewerten
wie viel verantwortung trägt sie dabei
und ist dieser verband an verantwortung
gerecht geworden jetzt hat sie
glücklicherweise für sich beantwortet
sie trägt natürlich verantwortung aber
sie ist ja auch gerecht geworden sie
möchte verteidigungsministerin bleiben
ist das für sie egal wie der wahlausgang
ist denkbar nach so einem debakel
also persönlich muss ich sagen durch das
versagen dieser drei ministerien ich
hier gerade benannt habe sind menschen
konkret in lebensgefahr geraten und es
sind minister schon aus geringeren
gründen zurückgetreten und ich finde das
wirklich
ich würde es mal diplomatisch sagen ein
ausdruck von enormer rutschte jetzt sich
hinzustellen und zu sagen was bei der
wahl passiert ich meine die union ist
bei 20% wir wissen noch gar nicht wie
die nächste bundesregierung aussieht
aber frau kramp karrenbauer verteilt
schon ihren posten an sich selber als es
tut mir leid das finde ich ein verhalten
das wird der lage überhaupt nicht
gerecht noch eine frage zum thema sie
haben es eben erwähnt abschiebung da hat
ihr parteifreund kubicki gestern gesagt
naja wenn sich die lage stabilisiert und
die taliban die regierung so bilden wie
sie das im moment anstreben dann müssen
wir natürlich wieder nach afghanistan
abschieben kann man in afghanistan das
von den taliban mit der scharia regiert
ist abschieden also wenn ich so die
berichte von paul ronzheimer sehe und
höre was der erzählt dann finde ich bei
aller frustration über das versagen der
bundesregierung bei allem ärger über die
straftäter die wir hier haben es
humanitär schwer vorstellbar da leute
hin abzuschieben was ronzheimer daher
berichtet hat ist das eben scharia
strafen verhängt werden körperstrafen
abgehackte hände und dann fürchterliche
dinge das wollen wir nicht als wenn es
so kommt dann muss ich sagen werde ich
mit wolfgang kubicki darüber noch mal
diskutieren wir müssen natürlich auch
überlegen wie gehen wir jetzt mit den
taliban mit dem regime
da geht es natürlich auch um finanzielle
hilfen im interview mit paul ronzheimer
dass wir gestern abend ausgestrahlt
haben die taliban sich sehr konziliant
geäußert haben die bundeskanzlerin sogar
eingeladen nach kabul und haben darum
gebeten weiterhin von deutschland
unterstützt zu werden
csu-landesgruppenchef alexander dobrindt
hat sich auch zu dem thema der
finanziellen unterstützung geäußert
gestern bei die richtigen fragen haben
wir mal kurz rein
wir reden hier ja jetzt von
schwerstverbrecher ja vergewaltiger
genau vieles andere mehr und
selbstverständlich habe das vorhin
gesagt ich will nicht dass sie hier auf
deutschen straßen herumlaufen das heißt
die müssten wieder zurückgeführt werden
in ihr heimatland die müssen bis dahin
auch möglicherweise in abschiebehaft
genommen werden das ist machbar
und wir müssen die situation in
afghanistan natürlich genau beobachten
die taliban haben sich ja schon deutlich
geäußert sie wollen unterstützung
finanzielle hilfe im bereich jetzt auch
der arbeit der endlos welthungerhilfe
caritas ärzte ohne grenzen viele sind da
zurzeit auch unterwegs nach wie vor die
brauchen dann auch finanzielle
unterstützung die bundesregierung hat
bereits 600 millionen euro freigegeben
für die unterstützung auch genau dieser
organisationen in afghanistan vor ort
jemand der von uns meine ich die taliban
die wahrscheinlich neue regierung in
afghanistan wenn sie unterstützung haben
will an dieser stelle dann muss man auch
darüber verhandeln dass menschen
zurückgeführt werden die hier
gewaltverbrechen begehen oder schon
gewaltverbrechen begangen haben das
training kommt kein deutsches gericht
würde auch nur einen tag lang das
mitmachen das darunter erzählt das ist
reine augenwischerei kein deutsches
gericht sieben leute noch jemand nach
griechenland ab wegen der situation und
moorea kein deutsches gericht was
dobrindt da erzählt reine wahlkampfshow
bekannt und sollten wieder ihr könnt ja
wir können ja sagen das ist
wünschenswert klar ich will die leute
auch nicht haben aber kein gericht in
unserem rechtsstaat würde zulassen dass
wir leute an die taliban ausliefern
punkt ganz einfach zwei punkte daher an
klingt die taliban wollen natürlich vor
allem unser geld deswegen geben sie sich
so freundlich der neuen
entwicklungshilfe der taliban-sprecher
hat bei uns im gespräch mit paul
ronzheimer auch gesagt sie wollen das
bildungssystem neu aufbauen und hätten
gern dafür deutsche steuer euros klare
frage deutsche steuer euros für die
taliban nein niemals nein was wir machen
und das ist man muss ein bisschen
trennen also eine
entwicklungszusammenarbeit zur stärkung
einer taliban regierung kann es nicht
geben punkt also das ist vollkommen klar
was es geben kann und geben wird ist
humanitäre unterstützung das heißt
einfach grundnahrungsmittel basis
medizinische versorgung durch die
vereinten nationen die da vor ort unter
sehr gefährlichen umständen ja auch noch
wie vor arbeiten das ist in ordnung das
machen wir immer das ist nicht politisch
aber auch schon oft schief gegangen in
der geschichte grundnahrungsmittel
werden oft eingesetzt somalia tragisches
bitteres beispiel werden oft eingesetzt
die richtigen kriegen dann die
grundnahrungsmittel ausgewählt von den
taliban die jenaer irgendwie
abweichender meinungen sind oder
angenehm werden dann ausdrucken ja das
war er sodann das beispiel kenne ich
aber richtig ist auch wenn wir das nicht
machen dann steigt der migrationsdruck
ist rihanna jetzt alle davon gerade auf
der cdu csu sah die reden jetzt auf 2015
darf sich nicht wiederholen nein da
sagen wir 2014 darf sich nicht
wiederholen bis 2014 passiert das
entwicklungshilfeministerium aus
deutschland und ein paar andere haben
aufgehört geld an die uno zu überweisen
die die menschen in den
flüchtlingslagern im libanon also die
flüchtlinge aus syrien ernährt haben die
hatten nichts mehr zu essen und haben
sich dann auf den weg gemacht also 2014
das sollten wir bei afghanistan nicht
wiederholen grundnahrungsmittel
versorgung sollten wir machen aber wir
sollten nicht hingehen deshalb ist die
fdp gefordert bevor die regierung es
gemacht hat wir sollten nicht hingehen
und entwicklungshilfe an die taliban
seien gerd müller der
entwicklungshilfeminister also für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit sieht das
anders er hat sich den forderungen der
un angeschlossen durchaus
entwicklungshilfe zu geben das kann er
gerne tun wir sind in der demokratie
drei wochen vor der wahl die bürgerinnen
und bürger können sich ein bild davon
machen wer entwicklungshilfe für die
taliban will kann cdu csu wählen wer das
nicht will kann fdp wählen die
bundeskanzlerin ist eingeladen worden
auf das herzlichste von den taliban der
taliban-sprecher hat gesagt man würde
sie herzlich empfangen zwei fragen
erstens sollte die bundeskanzlerin
hinfahren und noch mal selber mit den
taliban sprechen zweitens glauben sie
dass wir so was in den nächsten wochen
vielleicht tatsächlich sehen werden eine
große konferenz auf außenministerebene
zum beispiel wo dann heiko maas zum
beispiel mit den taliban verhandeln
würde direkt also die bundeskanzlerin
sollte nicht fahren sie hat in letzter
zeit sowieso bei ihren besuchen nicht so
glückliches händchen gehabt ich erinnere
an den blumenstrauß von putin am
jahrestag der vergiftung von alexei
navalny das war völlig unmöglich sie
sollte definitiv nicht fahren würdest
die konferenz wird verhandlungen mit
vertretern der taliban geben das gibt es
seit zwei jahren schon in doha in katar
reden die amerikaner ja mit den taliban
das abkommen der amerikaner über den
abzug ist von februar 2020 und dass es
da kontakte gibt das erwarte ich einfach
auch deswegen weil man natürlich noch
zum teil deutsche staatsangehörige in
afghanistan haben die wir aus holen
wollen also insofern da gespräche zu
führen das hielte ich nicht für verkehrt
aber eine andere ebene natürlich letzte
frage haben deutsche staatsangehörige in
afghanistan die sagen dass gerade wir
wissen inzwischen wir haben über 200
menschen ohne papiere nach deutschland
gelassen gebracht mit der luftwaffe hat
die bundesregierung deutsche
staatsangehörige muss man es so klar
sagen im stich gelassen zurückgelassen
in afghanistan denn ja klar die
bundesregierung hatte kein konzept für
den abzug obwohl wir das wir haben es im
bundestag immer wieder gefordert dass
freidemokraten machten exit-strategie
irgendwann kommt der abzug wie soll das
ablaufen welche szenarien sind
vorstellbar und das szenario war jetzt
nicht so erwartet aber es war jedenfalls
auch nicht völlig unplanbar und da es
keine planung gab sind die menschen die
jetzt da zurückgelassen worden sind von
dieser bundesregierung im stich gelassen
wir haben immer wieder auch kontakt zu
solchen leuten schalten immer wieder
nach afghanistan da sind wirklich
bewegende momente wie weinen sie wissen
nicht weiter ich mein was sagt man denen
jetzt dienen sagt man da brauchen wir
euch politisch zu diskutieren denen sagt
man dass egal wer regiert in deutschland
ist wird jetzt alles getan um die leute
herauszuholen und sie nach hause zu
bringen die haben das verdient sie haben
jedenfalls nicht verdient dort ausharren
zu müssen weil die bundesregierung diese
fehler gemacht hat aber das ist jetzt
wirklich ein imperativ der auch nach der
wahl gilt alexander graf lambsdorff fdp
dank film besuchen vielen dank ich danke
[Musik]